[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and welcome to this very special part
two of our discussion with me and
francis this time we're going to be
talking about the big things that we
think are coming up in the next couple
of years the things that we're going to
be focusing on the guests we're going to
be targeting and the types of
conversations we think are going to be
needed and also why i really don't like
stuart lee's comedy and of course for
those of you who are on locals you've
submitted a bunch of questions which
we'll be answering and putting up on
locals only for those of you who want to
check it out so francis without any
further ado mate we talked about the
past of the show where we've come from
if people haven't seen that already i
actually think a lot of people will be
quite shocked at the journey that we've
had so far and perhaps at some of the
lowest lows and where we've come from
and how it was when we started uh but
we've done a couple of these in in the
past where we we we called them
trigonometry destroys trigonometry uh
and that's just me interviewing you you
interviewing me um and we thought given
that we've just moved on to
a new set that we've got a whole new
thing going on it also seems to be a
sort of interesting time because
hopefully i think it's fair to say is it
in certainly in the uk at least that
covet is starting to die down are we are
we are we going to be that optimistic do
you think well look in the uk as thing
stands on whatever day it is i think
it's the 13th of november now as we're
recording it yeah as we're recording it
it does look like the threat of covetous
receiver is receding we're not seeing
this the number of hospitalizations or
deaths that we saw
last winter or indeed at the first stage
of the pandemic so you would hope so
however
if you look at around the world austria
has just now gone into a lockdown yeah
yeah
i'm vaccinated people i think the dutch
are proposing a lock down or they're
about to go into a lockdown uh
australia's just [ __ ] the bed
and new zealand uh they've gone
absolutely insane
but what i mean though is i mean it's
going to get to a point eventually where
the numbers are just so low
you can't really carry on with this
right i mean it's going to become
endemic in the uk people are arguing it
already has and
possibly in other parts of around the
world the economics of this are also
unsustainable and we'll maybe talk about
that in a minute but i do feel at least
maybe today tomorrow could be different
but i do feel
that my prediction that i made earlier
which is there would be another lockdown
this winter doesn't seem to be true in
the uk no it's been true in other
countries but in the uk it's not which
suggests to me
that the vaccine has worked to reduce
the number of people in hospital and the
number of people dying to a point where
as a society you know christopher
snowden who will hopefully get on the
show soon he's just written an article
talking about how basically covert with
people vaccinated at the level that they
are now covert is like the flu yeah
which we've just lived with and we have
done for generations so
i think
i'm optimistic that other things are
going to start to be the thing that
everyone cares about because my concern
with covid
once the initial mass wave of people
dying and all of that happening
was passed was that
because we're all so obsessed about
covert all the time there are actually a
lot of other issues
that are going unnoticed uncovered
undiscussed
uh some of them are consequence of
covert some of the consequences lock
down some of them are just a consequence
of where we are as a society
and those things are going to start
popping up and we can talk about more of
that the number one thing for me is
inflation
it's already happening if you remember
at the beginning of covet we interviewed
pippa malngram and jim rickards and this
was what they said they said inflation
is coming and now it's here
a lot of people aren't aware of it
because the media haven't started
covering it but the reality is
if we go back to 2008
we our response to the financial crisis
was essentially to empty the medicine
cupboard we threw everything at it and
by everything i mean we printed a ton of
money we dropped interest rates to
historically unprecedented levels and
they've been there ever since basically
right that isn't that it's not how
that's not a sustainable thing over the
long term and yet we've been at it for
13 years now so
add to that the huge cost of furlough
and lockdown and and the hit to the
economy and all of that
you're going to see prices rising you
already are seeing that in some other
things and partly that's to do with
supply and chain issues but barley is to
do with the fact that if you have more
money chasing fewer goods you're going
to get inflation and what that means is
people savings get eroded etc so i think
economics is going to start to come back
to the table which ironically is where
the show started if you think about our
first few episodes that's what we talked
about because that was one of the
biggest issues at the time yeah and it
was because of brexit and we were
talking about economics in relation to
brexit no you've what you're saying is
100 accurate plus factoring in the price
of goods are going to rise things like
petrol that's already rising we
literally went to the petrol station
yesterday and you were shocked at how
much it had risen fuel prices are going
to rise so they're talking about
people's
utility bills increasing by something by
25 if not 50
and that's before greta get her hands on
it yeah exactly so
these are all going to be up for
discussion i don't think covert is going
to go away and and i'll tell you why and
this is going to make me sound like a
conspiracy theorist code is a very
powerful tool because it creates fear in
people and once you create fear in
people they become easier to manipulate
they become that that therefore means
they become
easier for you to get what you want
the government can get what they want
far easier when the populists are afraid
and they're scared but you're not
suggesting they're going to keep covered
running even when it's the numbers
aren't high are you
i'm going to say that they're going to
use any opportunity they can to try and
get vaccine passports in place
why do you think that why do i think
that why do you think that's what they
want why do i think that's what they
want because they want to be able to
essentially
monitor our whereabouts at all points
i just think that's the way things are i
think data is power being able to track
your citizens means that you have power
and the part of the vaccine possible
situation is just another way in order
to track people and i think they're
going to want to bring us in
uh my partner went to america and look
this is an example of what is happening
and people and we need to get we need to
talk about this because i don't think
people really understand
my partner went back went to new york
where she's from
everything in new york is vax passport
vax passport vac's passport you
literally can't go in
to a coffee shop and grab it and grab a
coffee without showing a vax passport
that's where it is right
now
she went to a conference as part of her
job when she got admitted into the
conference center the security guards
and the people at this went we need to
show your vaccination status she said
okay here's my card right this way miss
we're also going to need to take your
temperature she said right okay
they took her temperature at the but at
the same time as taking a temperature
they also scanned her face and because
she's very aware and very up on tech and
the issues around tech she went hold on
a second i gave you permission to scan
my temperature or to take my temperature
i did not give you permission to scan my
face
my worry
and i've got a sneaking suspicion of the
government are going to do this they're
going to use it as an opportunity to
track us and grab our data and that can
be anything from facial scans
right the way through to whatever else
is going to happen though i'm not
technologically okay with
and for those of you who are watching
this listening to me going to me oh
you're a conspiracy theorist blah blah
blah smoking too much weed
guilty of that probably however
my question to you would be what's
happened to cash
no one's talking about it but cash has
disappeared
for example you go to pretty much in
london
they know they no longer accept cash
there are many branches of chains right
the way through the city of london
they're no longer upset you know i think
that's a good thing it's just convenient
no i don't think it's a good thing
because cash is very very important cash
number one is a way for you not to be
tracked it's a way for the government to
have nothing to do with your finances
with your financial transactions the
government saw
covid as an opportunity to get rid of
cash to take cash off the table do you
remember why they said that we couldn't
have cash yeah it's because uh you could
pass covert through physical contact
okay but that has now been debunked well
they said a lot of things that have been
deployed right so yeah okay and the part
and give them their due we didn't know
at the time
but cash isn't coming back i'm telling
you that now
cash is not coming back
everything will now be on card they've
increased the limit on card to 100
pounds
with the tap
so that therefore makes it easier again
it is just another way for them to be
able to track us more effectively yeah
and i think
maybe if if you just talk about it from
a sort of power grab point of view
people will think you're being
conspiratorial about it but actually if
you look at it from a government point
of view well this is a way
to
help people it's a way to track people's
health status so you can get them the
right help that's how people will be
justifying it potentially in their head
so i see what you're saying
um
it's interesting because i i'm not sure
they're going to be able to get vaccine
passports through in this country
they've already gotten through in
scotland and they've already got them
through in wales that is very true
so they are going to do everything they
possibly can
everything they possibly can
right
we were talking about you and i doing
gigs in scotland and because we've got a
big scottish audience and we were
talking about getting a scottish guest
and talking about not many of them but
they are big
exactly you're going to make that joke
in glasgow i'm going to leave and you
can deal with the consequences
but you need vax passports now in
scotland
so they've got them in wells they've got
them in scotland why are they not going
to try and bring them here
well i think two years ago i would have
said because we've got a libertarian
yeah in power but i don't think we found
that to be the case so you think the
fight for civil liberties in terms of
the government surveillance government
controlling and tracking your movements
etc that's going to be one of the big
issues that stays on the table yeah the
government under covered laws abolished
the right to protest
i'm going to say that again just for
people who didn't understand that they
abolished the right to protest what do
you mean
it meant that you couldn't congregate in
past groups of five in order to protest
in order to make your feelings heard
because of the pandemic because
surely once the pandemic is over that
will come back people might say right
okay yeah but the only reason it came
back was because of the outcry of sarah
about what happened with the sarah
everard murder where there was a women's
vigil right if it was anti-lockdown
protesters no one would give a [ __ ] the
only reason people were outraged is
because that picture went viral of that
police officer kneeling on that woman's
back and as ella wieland made the point
that happens all the time yeah including
to women but no one gives a [ __ ] as long
as they've got the wrong opinions
exactly right but that was the only
reason and suddenly people woke up and
were like this is disgusting i'm like oh
yeah but when it's anti-lockdown when
it's something that you disagree with
then it's fine then people are stupid
then people are selfish and people you
know all the epithets that get hold what
people don't seem to realize is we have
the right to protest not for causes i
believe in or you believe in but because
it's vital for a democratic society and
what happened over codevid is we became
a police state
which brings us i think on to the third
issue that is going to be very big in
the next couple of years or possibly
beyond and this is something actually to
give him his due matthew goodwin
predicted on the show a long time ago
is the politics of climate change
because
it's obviously been ramped up in recent
weeks and months
but you can see the
i i want to be careful because
you know it's something you're not
supposed to say about climate change but
i don't know what the truth is
about that issue i genuinely don't
i have other concerns related to the
environment i i think uh resource
depletion and pollution are very big
issues that need to be tackled one way
or another right without all this
hysteria and all this craziness but but
they are issues that are big
environmental issues
whether
human activity is the main driver of
climate change
i'm not a scientist i can't make a
determination either way like most
people i make my conclusions about this
issue based on what other people i
respect say and what i would say about
that is i keep being told that 99.999 of
the scientists agree blah blah blah
and it is true that a lot of people that
i respect
agree that climate change is caused by
human beings
i also would say that a lot of people
including scientists i know personally
who i respect are skeptical of that
fewer
far fewer but there are some right so i
genuinely don't know the truth of that
issue but what i do think is if under
the guise of dealing with climate change
we focused our resources on creating
stable energy supplies from things like
nuclear power for example which i don't
know why green people don't want to talk
about as much and we dealt with
pollution which is a huge issue and we
dealt with resource depletion which is a
huge issue that wouldn't be a bad thing
but the focus doesn't seem to be on that
the focus seems to be on this sort of
aoc
the world's ending in 12 years sort of
hysteria now there's generation of
people coming through now
and you see this with the protests that
are happening increasingly around the
world
they they they literally believe that
they believe the world is ending in 12
years now imagine if you believed the
world was ending in 12 years you'd be
able you'd not be able to you'd be
willing
to take some pretty drastic action glue
yourself to a road well
quite a lot more
imagine you genuinely thought like my
wife and i are about to have our first
child what would i be willing to do
if i thought the world is actually
ending in 11 years from now
as a
father
what would you be willing to do
yeah quite a lot yeah of course right
i mean it depends if i've had breakfast
yeah exactly in your case it does but do
you see what i'm saying of course if you
take this point of view literally
and that is one thing i think is
complete rubbish by the way i don't
think the world is ending in 12 years i
think that's nonsense
but if you do believe that
then you are going to glue yourself to a
road yeah and that's going to be the
starting point i mean if you
indoctrinate people with that level of
fear you talked about fear with covet
right what about the world ending in 12
years i mean that's going to scare a lot
of people particularly young people as
it already has i think
the politics of climate change or the
politics of the environment or whatever
green poll whatever you want to call it
that's going to get bigger and bigger
and bigger and even you and i have had
our arguments about this on raw you know
i remember you and i were talking about
whether extinction rebellion or
extremists and all of that right
that is going to be a huge issue
going forward i think because the
political and economic consequences of
that are going to be
gigantic to me the giant flaw in and
look i'm from your position
the one thing well that's not the one
thing one of the things that
trigonometry has given me is humility
the realization is what happens when you
work with me just the greatness being in
the presence of greatness exactly but
that's enough about anton right
but
it's a realization that i don't know a
lot
and when it comes to a subject like
climate change i know nothing
i i genuinely don't i don't know i know
nothing i'm not a scientist i'm not an
expert i haven't followed this story i
haven't delved deeply into it
i just haven't had the time
but the one thing that i find very
worrying is you look at the the person
the most prominent figure in this entire
movement and it's greta thumb
[Music]
and
she's an 18 year old kid who missed the
last few years at school
and is then
put on a platform and lecturing us
she doesn't even have a degree in this
she doesn't have a master she doesn't
have a phd she if it was some scientists
who'd been studying this for 30 years
and had won awards or it was widely
regarded and came out and said look
here's the data here's my research this
is what i think here are the reasons why
we're going to look at this over it then
i'd go okay well people would argue that
scientists have been doing that
and people haven't been listening
and the reason greta has worked as i
forget about her as a person just as a
as a device as a prop
is that
she embodies the
the panic
that people feel about
the doom the the you know what's coming
as a result of climate change because i
think
he is the reality is because i i'm not
convinced that it's happening but i'm
also not convinced that it's not
happening i genuinely don't know due to
human activity
then
what people are saying
is scary
and it's not scary in the sense of oh
you know east london is going to be
underwater it's scary in the sense of
if the sea levels do rise significantly
around the world what that means is a
lot of people are going to be displaced
yeah which is going to make the migrant
crisis of 2015 and recent years and and
all of that look like a walk in the park
you're gonna get
billions of people displaced
and and moving obviously to the west so
even from that perspective
it's it's going to cause a lot of
problems war famine starvation etc so
i think the reason greta works is that
she's
she's almost like
it's it's not a scientist even the kids
get it now do you know what i mean and
why are you dinosaur not getting with
the program i think that's part that's
why her chastising people i think is
such a big part of of the appeal
because she's she it's that sort of even
the kids get it why don't you you
old-fashioned you know whatever
idiot i think that's why it's working
okay i i get that's why it's working i'm
just saying it's not credible well she
people would argue she's standing on the
shoulders of scientists who've been
talking about this for a long time
more sensibly but they're being ignored
that's why you need to sort of panic
attack
approach
right i i don't think that's a way to do
things if i i just see
a movement
figureheaded by an 18 year old girl as
inherently ridiculous
that's ridiculous and i don't care if
you know you know she's briefed well or
whatever else
she's a kid
she's a young girl
why is it that she's been put on this
platform and the thing that i find very
dis and look
i'm not attack i'm genuinely not
attacking greta i'm gonna we make a lot
of jokes about greta
i'm gonna be honest with you
i feel deeply sorry for her i feel
deeply deeply sorry for her
insert jokes i used to teach but i used
to teach 15 year olds they're children
nobody should be put in that position
as an adult really it's not going to be
good for you and it's not going to be
helpful we talked about this in in the
first part of our conversation when i
was talking about my experience of being
in a much smaller media storm than she's
been in and i was saying that i'm
probably one of the more mentally
resilient people on the planet and yet
it's it's not easy to deal with at all
for her particularly given that she's
autistic and i know i have autistic
people in my family
i understand them pretty well it makes
life a lot harder i would imagine in the
situation and other mental health issues
that she's got going on
it is definitely not the kind thing to
do for her no
and she's a child
well not anymore no not anymore but i'm
glad i had to specify that man it's a
good look yeah with this tash yeah
but she's a child she was a child
and at that point when she became this
global celebrity
she had no idea what that was going to
entail what that was going to mean for
her life
for her future for the way people saw
her right from that point she became a
celebrity
every relationship moving forward has
been fundamentally changed because she's
become an icon and as a result of that
she's not going to know who's going to
be her real friends when she gets a
partner that partner are they with were
they with her because she is
they like her they love her for who she
is they want a better green action yeah
or is it because she's greta thunder
you
i see it personally as an act of great
cruelty because i don't think a 15 year
old has a capacity to consent
to what happened to her because i have
no way of understanding consequences any
consequences but be that level of
consequence and that level of fame i
don't think we understand what it must
be like to be that face no no we don't
we don't
but come back to the climate thing
because look the greta thing is i i i
agree with you
but it it's very
you know it's tangential to the issue i
think uh i i think even if greta wasn't
around it would still be a big of course
it'd still be a big issue
so i think that's gonna
that's gonna be the next big thing
uh well it's not the next big thing it's
one of the next big things and the
problem is that the reason i am very
skeptical about it
like i say i don't not believe i
genuinely if i if i didn't if i didn't
think climate change was man-made i
would say so
but i'm not sure that i can say that i
i'm agnostic about it it's the truth
but the problem is
the solutions that are being offered
don't make much sense to me
and i'll tell you why
nuclear energy is
statistically speaking as far as i
understand at least and i say this as
someone my wife grew up next to
chernobyl she had to be evacuated uh
from that era when it happened so i
understand the potential risks but
statistically speaking nuclear energy is
the safest form of energy that we have
yeah
right
and
every time you see these drives to you
know get people to buy electric cars or
like i bought a diesel car 10 years ago
whenever it was because peop i was told
this is this is the
for for long for long drives or whatever
it's much more energy efficient then it
turns out it's not now we're being told
we should buy electric cars well it
turns out electric cars are not energy
efficient either
and it turns out that yeah you can make
electric batteries but in order to do
that you've got to get you know a 14
north african kid mining cobalt in the
mines do you know what i mean so
that the the renewable energy that
people keep telling us is the next big
thing
it's not reliable at the moment and it's
not cost efficient at the moment right
so
i'm just
my my concern is
i don't know what's true but what i do
know is the the suggestions that we're
being given are number one not very
effective and number two
that you're talking about doubling
people's heating bills
really
the
the answer to everything at the moment
seems to be that we've got to pay more
tax and have fewer freedoms yeah right
i'm not sure i'm on board with that in
fact i'm pretty sure i'm not well you
did you not vote for corbin
surprisingly not
so
that's why i'm skeptical is that
look we can have a sensible conversation
about climate or resource depletion or
pollution and i think we should
but i'm not sure the answer
realistically even if the answer is to
get people to pay more i just don't know
that you're going to be able to achieve
that yeah and i i always think a lot of
the answer is going to come from
technology
technological progress rather than panic
um and that's
that like i said i think that's going to
be a big issue and we're going to have
to talk to more people who can explain
to us more about it that we don't
understand you know and in the next few
weeks we'll hopefully uh get uh michael
shellenberger on uh and bjorn lomborg as
well a couple of people who are sort of
uh
halfway on these issues they they i
think
we'll see what exactly they say but i i
want to be educated on the on this issue
more because i don't understand it very
well
hey constantine do you like christmas no
in ussr we cancelled christmas and we
had lenin fest instead hossack we
celebrated glorious leader and rewrote
story of jesus to make it better really
yes in our story three wise men were
killed and gifts meant for jesus
redistributed to glorious workers of the
soviet union jesus was put in gulag for
having wrong opinion as we call it in
russia happy ending
right well if you do want to celebrate
the festive season then there's only one
way to do it grab yourself a ticket to
our final live show of the year at the
leicester square theatre on saturday
december the 11th yes it is discussion
with one of our favorite guests aisha
akanbi she is almost as good philosopher
as vladimir
yeah exactly our two previous shows sold
out completely and this one will as well
grab your ticket now before it's too
late click on link below during interval
there will be special entertainment i
will ride bear with my shirt off i
didn't realize we were going for that
demographic mate oh yes we are x
and that's
and that's the point the problem is
is that when you look at the climate
change debate
to me
it's encased in hyperbole
there's we've got what have i heard
we've got 50 good harvest left
that's what that's that's one thing i've
heard i can see why that trouble yeah
yeah that would really upset me uh the
the fact that you know that certain
parts of the world will be underwater
the other parts will be on fire the
other parts will become uninhabitable
that the forest fire that the fires in
australia
and california are just a starter
and then what we're going to see is
going to be even worse over the coming
years right
and you and you're looking at this
and i don't
see i i can't see
sensible rational discussion well for
starters in terms of fires and other
individual climate events no legitimate
scientist would ever claim to be able to
directly correlate an individual fire
which had been happening for millennia
for millions of years in fact with a a
specific trend in the climate you can't
no no credible scientist would claim
to be able to prove that sort of
causality
and we had this situation the other day
with this cop 26 happening and some like
it was someone i think from a major
major news organization who said i'm on
the train to glasgow there's leaves
caused by climate change on on the
tracks
right people are now starting to to
pretend that everything is to do with
climate change well actually is that
really true do you know what i mean and
the more this hysteria continues the
harder it's going to be to believe yeah
yeah and look i'm going to be honest
with you when it's this doomsday's
prophecies
i don't want to engage with it
when it's things you know you you read
an article about how
everything's dead the you know
the oceans are empty there are no more
fish ever
you go well what's the point
what's the point you need to give people
a sense of hope
now they can do something about it
i
think it's really important that we sit
down and actually have a proper
discussion about this we actually have a
proper discussion instead of what it
feels like which is fear-mongering we
will we will definitely do that we've
got guests coming up and we'll keep
exploring that issue but let's talk
about cultural stuff because so far
we've talked about the big chunky things
which
uh was actually one of the things one of
the reasons we started the show we
wanted to discuss the big serious issues
economics yeah client you know politics
all of that sort of thing yeah yeah and
climb you know we it wasn't a big issue
at the time but it has become one
what about culture what do you see as
the cultural issues that keep coming up
do you think do you think they they went
you know i say they the sort of woke
left they went for race they went so the
way i see it is they started with with
feminism right and they tried to
alienate men from women and women from
men and it didn't quite work yeah right
now you're starting to see a big push
back in america particularly where this
stuff really originated against critical
race theory against teaching white
people that they're guilty and teaching
black people that they're oppressed
and you're starting to see some
successes in in that fight back parents
going into schools and saying we won't
stand for this elections are now being
turned on this issue etc
do you think the race thing is going to
die down
or do you think it's going to run and
run
i think look
i think part of this is again to do with
covert and i think we descended into
insanity
in june 2020 when we saw
everything that happened with the murder
of george floyd all the repercussions
all the demonstrations that was a form
of hysteria brought about by physically
locking people in their own homes and
then mainlining social media into their
eyeballs 24 7.
that was a result of that
i don't think we're going to get to that
peak again
i don't think we're going to see that
level of hysteria
but i think it's going to carry on
i think it's going to carry on because
but do you not think it's just got too
ridiculous now
like they literally call it they're
calling black people white supremacists
now you don't think that at some point
that they just they're just going to
become so discredited that no one
listens to them anymore
because i see this i see people talking
about this now popping up on cnn that
idiot brian stelter now is actually
having reasonable conversations about
this bill maher who i've always
respected anyway but he's now saying
look if if crt is about telling black
people they're not going to make it and
white people that they're evil i'm out
people are becoming more emboldened and
speaking out against her as the
craziness becomes more
aggressive
okay am i just being too hopeful
maybe you are being too helpful and too
optimistic but then you look at things
like the labour party and you saw that
clip where he was where he was saying
you know there's too many white men
speaking yeah
i think this is already endemic in the
culture the seats have already been sunk
right but but isn't that but do you not
think that because it's that ridiculous
people are going to turn off it because
look we talked about this um
off camera and i actually think this is
a good point to bring up the labour
party
you know
the only the only way the labour party
becomes relevant again is if they start
addressing real issues
right real issues being the housing
crisis yeah inequality
right these are the things that people
in this country actually care about but
they don't want to be relevant
they want to be right
we always say this we all have this
discussion they don't care they don't
care about being relevant they just
can't was the case in the in the mid 90s
yeah and then blair comes along and
brown comes along and mandela comes
along and they transform the party they
take it towards the center and they say
look let's stop obsessing about how we
divide the pie and how evil the tories
are and actually talk about growing the
pie yeah but there wasn't social media
then
social media has played a huge factor
these people have got enormous sway and
power there are people on the momentum
left we've got hundreds of thousands of
followers on twitter who can create a
twitter storm
but you don't think loss after loss
after loss after loss in elections
this is going to get them to change them
no look at the people we knew in the
comedy industry yeah but they're idiots
in the comedy industry yeah but
they were all in the labour party and
they're all in that particular side of
the labor but the labour party does have
a lot of sensible people the paul
embrace of the world right a lot of
people have left the labour party who
are sensible constantine a friend of
ours you know who is
uh
tom buick who i do who i i know very
well he's a former he was a for he
former advisor educational advisor to
the gordon brown government he resigned
from labor
because of brexit
there's a lot of very sensible very sane
people who have left the labour party
you go okay look paul embry namely three
other people who you think are sensible
in labor
yeah
i i suspect there are more people who
are sensible and labor the problem is
they're not prominent yeah that's why i
don't know their names yes
and we say all right the labour party
are going to be sensible
well
well let's go back to cervix gate
should women be allowed to should should
you should be able to say that women
have a cervix
[Music]
kirsten would behave like he'd just seen
a cervix in front of him he just
right in front of him in glorious
technicolor he didn't know what to say
david lammy said something ridiculous
like maybe you can grow your own
what's something along those lines we
might be able to we're going to need to
fact check that i'm not sure that's what
you said yeah but
maybe something along those lines i
can't remember i just remember it was
equally demented yeah and look but to be
fair so did boris yeah
right now boris didn't boris dealt with
it
he didn't you forget
we
have a go at boris all the time
we don't actually acknowledge how
skillful boris can be and boris dealt
with that beautifully he just went look
i believe it's important that we treat
everyone with kindness and respect do
you remember that yep
you know and you know you know there is
biological sex but there's also gender
and every time kindness and respect
what a [ __ ] right but he dealt with it
brilliantly yeah yeah well for a
politician for a politician didn't
answer the question right he didn't
answer the question and made everyone
feel like he agreed with them yes
exactly right but labor
can't either the head of the labour
party
can't even say that women have a cervix
so how are you going to appeal to women
mate
david it's a question i've been trying
to work out for a long time
unsuccessfully david lammy
again there's people who have very
strong opinions of david lammy he's a
very intelligent man he's harvard
educated
he's lost he's lost his mind on this as
well so that being the case when are
they going to win
but that's my point they're not going to
win for a very long time and i imagine
the process of losing over and over and
over
produces a desire to change things
that's what happened to labor in the
early 90s
the party had been banging on about the
same outdated [ __ ] that the public
didn't care about they lost economic
credibility they weren't respected and
they hadn't been elected for ages right
and eventually someone comes along who
believes in in the key stuff and look we
should talk about inequality and and uh
the economics before we go that before
we go there and we will talk about that
i'm with brett weinstein on this
i think the labour party is done
did he say that no but he said our
institutions
and i think the labour party is an
institution that is no longer fit for
purpose
that is completely discredited
they'll come into the party state
and as a result
it's finished
interesting
i don't know about that i don't know
about that i think they if with the
right people in charge
well where was tony blair in in 1987 he
was a lawyer no one had heard of him
right but he came in and look it sounds
like i'm praising tony blair in this
bloody shot i'm not a fan in terms of
his iraq policy his immigration policy
and whatever but you can't deny
transform the labour party was one of
the most successful in terms of
electorally british prime ministers in
modern history right
so people like that come along every now
and again and and they change
they can change direction the direction
of the party
but
but the way that you do that though
francis is you start talking to
the majority
and what do the majority of people in
this country care about they care about
economic inequality and increasingly we
talked about this as well
housing right particularly people of our
generation and our generation i remind
you is getting older right we are now
middle-aged
no we're not
we're not
explain explain
well
i may be 39 but i identify
as 29.
okay
so you're old i'm getting there as well
so my point is
if people of our generation which they
are are unable to buy property right
that's going to be a huge issue
politically and electorally
and the party that addresses that i
think will will have
the support of
the people who are there at that time
for generations
for generations that would be whoever
can sort that issue out
is going to have
incredible widespread support
particularly if they're a
tory particularly if they're a tory
because what that will then happen is
they will have they will retain the
support of the shire tories even though
those people don't necessarily want the
housing problem to be fixed and in many
ways it's not in their interest to have
the housing problem fixed but they'll
still vote tory
and then
you get
ordinary people working class people on
board with that because they're the ones
that are suffering the most it's not the
kids of the of the lawyer and the banker
who are not able to get on the housing
market
right yeah yeah it's ordinary people
but look we've spoken about this in many
a car drive it does it's not in their
interest to sort this
i think it's coming to the point you
made this point charlotte gill
charlotte gill who who who's the deputy
editor of conservative woman
tom harwood who is clearly a
right-leaning
journalist on gb news all i see when i
look on twitter is those two complaining
about not being not being able to get on
the housing ladder and renting forever
yeah right now if people like that
are struggling to get on the housing
ladder what does that mean for someone
who you know who's got
who's got a not quote unquote normal job
someone who works in a supermarket
someone who who who drives a van and is
an electrician or whatever these are
very necessary important jobs yeah and
they are much more representative of the
country than tom harwood or charlotte
charlotte gill right
but
i think we forget man
this is one of the things that has
happened in the last
50 60 70 years
you used to be able to feed a family of
four
on one person's income and when i mean
feed i mean have a house
right in america this was very much the
case think about the movies from from
the 50s yeah right mum was at home
yeah how it should be
you know what i mean right one income
feeds a family of four and and that
person wasn't a ceo of a bank no that
person worked in a factory yeah they
worked in an office they weren't
necessarily you know creating a
multi-million dollar business they were
just a normal person who went to work
did their duty by their family buy their
country whatever and they were fine
is that possible now no can you feed a
family of four on one income no in a
normal job so so for all the progress we
keep talking about how we've made
progress on this and progress on that
and we no longer mean to gays or
whatever which is great
but the reality is economically
society's regressed
now you can buy better things and
quality of life has improved but
people have now found themselves in a
wage trap
right where housing prices keep going up
massively wages are not and more and
more members of your family have to work
to keep to keep you fed right
that is a problem yeah that is a problem
it's a problem societally because what
happens is you know peter hitch talked
about in a live show no one no one's
supposed to talk about this because
we're all supposed to pretend that the
the emancipation of women has been
consequence-free right and it's been a
great thing that people can do what they
want with their life no one wants women
back in the kitchen or any of that but
at the same time if you are if you're
telling me that all women want to be a
wage slave in an office rather than
raising their own children at home well
you're lying yeah and and what happens
when
children aren't being raised by their
parents they're being shipped off to
school at the age of three which is
what's happening now i know people
who've got kids who are two and three
years old very few of them are being
cared by their own parents no they get
sent to nursery at school schools now
have nurseries primary schools right
do you honest does anyone is anyone
honestly trying to tell me
that a generation of children who've
basically barely seen their parents
and are in some kind of mass
indoctrination system by the age of
three are you telling me that that is
better for this for society
no
so
we've regressed massively as a result of
the economic situation in which more and
more people they're not given the option
see the the emancipation thing was about
options it was about giving people
freedom but what we've ended up instead
is people not having the freedom people
being forced into a particular pipeline
by the economic circumstances where you
work or die
both parents have to work
or your quality of life is going to be
that much worse that it's just it's not
a decision most people can afford to
make
i mean look
this is actually one of the benefits of
covert
in that
the reality is now
for a lot of jobs you that you don't and
shouldn't have to be in the office five
days a week
most people
you could argue one day a week they go
into the office they do what they need
to do or maybe two which means they
don't have to live in cities which means
they can live outside of london which
means that the property is more
affordable which means they will have a
better quality of life because they'll
be around their kids for longer yeah but
the reality is as well
this is a problem and this is again why
i have a problem with the left pointing
the finger at the right
because
blair didn't solve this problem it
started with thatcher
then it was handed on to major he didn't
solve it
then it went to blair he didn't do
anything about it even though he's on
the left and you'd think he'd be
building council houses because that's a
class classic or just houses or houses
but particularly council houses because
we never replenish the stock once
thatcher built them
then we moved thatcher sold them off yes
sorry once that just sold them off thank
you and then now 11 years of a tory
government who have done nothing about
it whatsoever
so this has been a problem for
since i was born
and you are now approaching crisis point
we're not even approaching we're now at
crisis point and what do we do
and what do we do about it because the
reality is that is having an impact
right the way through our culture like
we always say about millennials oh blah
blah blah you know they don't grow up
they don't you know they're always
moaning they're always behaving like
children they're in their 30s but of
course they're behaving like children
they live like teenagers they live like
22 year olds in in a flat share five to
a flat share of course you're going to
behave like a teenager because what
incentive have you got to settle down
what incentives have you got to have
kids if you can't buy a place how can
you be conservative you've got nothing
to conserve it's it's ridiculous
so
i have a great deal of sympathy for our
generation
and people looking down and saying oh
you know you're feckless and you're
behaving in a manner that is immature
but there's no point in being mature
because you can't live a mature life so
what's the point i mean my only
challenge to that would be that it is
possible to get through that but it's
just that much harder
it's that much harder for a lot of
people it's impossible yeah to buy it
much harder i would argue but yeah yeah
i always think
whatever the circumstances you've got to
strive to overcome them but i agree with
you it's that much harder for people you
know and the people every practically
everyone that i know and again this is
anecdotal information who has bought a
place has done it because of the
inherited money
yeah one
but everybody else are you just hanging
around with loser comedians of course
that's the case
no the people that all that i know the
people who have bought places is because
their parents or their grandparents
getting money and look they've got good
jobs and that means that they can afford
it but
granite died they got 70 grand that
means they put a deposit down on a flat
and i'm not i am bitter i'm gonna
retract that
but you the society can't function like
that
because then you've got people from the
lowest economic strata who want to
improve who want to move their life
forward and they're seeing this entire
section of society just closed off to
them
it's true look we've talked about it a
lot and i'm sure we'll keep talking
about it i think we should cover one
more topic before we go to our local
questions which is comedy what do you
think is the future of comedy because
i've taken a step back from it from the
moment i'm working on my book which will
be out middle of next year um
that's been my project that i've i've
been doing in addition to trigonometry
which takes up an extraordinary amount
of our time even though we keep growing
the team and every time we can afford to
we hire a new person to help us do a bit
more of the show
whereas you've you've
you've been focusing on on getting ready
for your tour and getting your show
ready
so i imagine you have some thoughts on
on comedy and where it might be going
right as far
comedy it's the best of times and the
worst of times
it's the best of times because
look around look what we've done look
what we've created we were two comedians
with no backing no finances nothing yeah
but we had to give up everything right
we had to risk everything to do this
yeah and for every one of us there will
be 20 people who failed yeah who didn't
make it who are not successful you know
and by the way when we say successful i
still think of us as a tiny youtube
channel we are a tiny youtube channel
compared to where we're going yeah right
but for every one of us there's 20 or
maybe 200 or maybe 2 000 people who had
an idea who gave it a bit of a shot and
never quite made it yeah but that's
comedy how many people start on the open
mic true who true have it have a dream
whatever else and
yeah we're just better
carry on and it didn't succeed so if you
have a dream if you have a dream if
you've got talent if you've got drive if
you have got discipline good luck yeah
exactly great tasha's then
there's a chance you can do something
and there's a chance that you can grow
following there's a chance that actually
you'll be able to calm out a niche for
yourself
so there is that
the problem is in the mainstream the
problem is when it comes to
political comedy for example
where
i was talking with this guy in comedy
this committee this producer a
commissioner a couple of days ago tv
chemistry tv commissioner that's the one
and uh we were talking about stuart lee
and i said look i think stuart lee is
great he's overrated but that's another
conversation for another time
i don't agree with you actually he
wouldn't have made it in america mate
sorry yeah but that's because british
people are not just that's cause
american comedians are better it's a
higher standard fact no no see i don't
know this is not true francis you don't
like stuart lee because he's a snob no
and i like stuart lee because he's a
snob
that's the difference stuart lee is he
he pioneered a different style of comedy
that is something very special
he you can't you just can't compare him
to bill but it's a different way of
doing comedy it's just a different thing
for a different audience and done in a
very different way he is a genius at
comedy
that you just happen to be triggered by
it which is fine you're entitled to that
view
because he is a snob he's an
intellectual snob
and there's an audience of people there
for that
that's all no
anyway i disagree he's overrated but
anyways
you're right okay so you've got stuart
lee and i was talking to him and i was
saying look comedy's biased he went give
me an example i went okay stuart lee
you've got a stuart lee of the left why
is there not a stuart lee of the right
and he went why should we have a stuart
liu of the right
and i went well it's called balance
isn't it yeah and he went all right what
would stewart lily of the right talk
about i said well they'd criticize greta
thundberg number one because greta
thundberg
why has she been given the platform that
she has she's not a climate scientist
she doesn't have all the arguments i
spoke about before he went well that's
got nothing to do with politics that's
social
and i went well it's got to do with
politics because
her what she wants to implement
in this country and around the world is
going to affect us and it's going to
affect our politic it went oh what else
i went well blm
why is it that everybody went nuts over
an organization that has the words in it
abolish capitalism defund the police why
did no one investigate or challenge
these ideas and he went well look
you've got i think you know i agree with
the fact that black lives matter i said
i'm like mate i'm not disagreeing with
the fact that black lives matter
you know yeah i i agree with that i
think
99.9 percent of people do right and if
you don't you're a
desperately unpleasant human being right
nobody very few people are disagreeing
with yeah but it's a deliberate
conflation yeah it's a deliberate
conflation anyway and then he got very
awkward shook my hand and walked off
yeah and these are the people who run
comedy these are the people who run
comedy these are the taste makers these
are the people so what you have
is you have sacred cows in comedy that
you were never gonna be able to touch
you are never going to be able to go for
you're never going to be able to take
the piss out but
but
here's where i push back comedy
unleashed yeah are talking to tv yeah
they did a pilot so at least tv are
interested in in exploring that people
are talking to us about doing a
satirical show on tv right now whether
that's going to happen or not we don't
know
but to me the fact that those
conversations they were not being had
three years ago yeah right they're being
had now maybe
a few years from now
see this is the problem it's your
optimism
it lets you down time and time again
it does mate for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction right
the pendulum swings don't you think
no i don't know what do you mean that no
no
i've been right about everything no you
haven't yes i have and you were going to
me there's going to be a lot of lockdown
no they're not it's gonna be they're
gonna do vaccine passports that's gonna
happen
listen to foster adamus listen mate with
that taj you're more nonstop yeah
but
no i don't think so i don't think so
because
you are going to have to change the
people
for that to happen yeah but all but but
all it takes though francis it look if
you and i
and it's going to sound you know big
headed and whatever but
but genuinely if you and i
remember the work that was that we did
and we'll be doing more of it
if we did that with with a tv budget and
a tv project behind us
that would be the most popular comedy
show in this country you really think
they're going to let us go on tv and
take the piss out of blm is that really
what you're saying
maybe for one show
you really think they're going to let
two
middle aged in your words straight white
males come on
and and take the piss out you can take a
bumming yeah
and i'll you know i'll brown out brown
up a bit more and then we can be diverse
yeah
i j i look god bless you in your
optimism and your immigrant optimism and
we can change things and
no
it's not going to happen and when i went
to and i'd talk to these people it just
isn't it's not the bbc i love the bbc
i do
i do and and i take no joy in seeing it
being criticized i take no joy
in seeing what it's becoming i take no
joy in any of it
but it can't change
because the people
in there are all the same type of people
with the same and they're not bad people
they're not bad people but they should
be killed but they should be killed no
they're not bad people
but they just think and view the world
in a particular way well [ __ ] it then
we'll do it ourselves but this is a
point and this is why this exists and
this is why we've achieved we'll just do
it ourselves once we have enough
resources to allocate enough time to
doing the satirical stuff we'll start
doing that yeah if they don't want to do
it on tv [ __ ] them we'll make it
ourselves and we'll make it bigger and
then they're gonna come cap in hand
asking us to come on their show and
we'll tell them to go [ __ ] themselves
and you look at how what has happened to
all the satirical shows look at charlie
brooker
well it got [ __ ] and then it ended yeah
as far as i know it used to be
incredible yeah that's what if we made
the show that's what it would be like
yeah of course but better but you know
yeah but we're
but we're both huge fans of charlie
brooker we you know
working yeah it's early work brilliant
what it became now yeah it's unwatchable
so there we go
there we go i don't think it's going to
change because the people in it
view
certain issues in a particular way and
i'll tell you why it's because we've
conflated politics with morality it's
not about arguments anymore it's not
about debate it's about morality i don't
think it's that although that is a
factor
it's a more complicated thing because
politics is always partly about morality
in my opinion i think we've conflated
comedy with politics
that's the real reason comedy is
struggling if we've conflated comedy
with politics everything now is
political you can't just make fun of
politicians without people assuming that
you are on the side of the other people
yeah when did that happen but what does
that mean though to the side of the
other people let's dig into that
it means that you you are an activist as
opposed to a comedian but and let's go
deeper what does that mean if you're an
activist for the other side no i know
where you're trying to take this but i
don't agree i don't think i don't think
you i think the argument about
conflating politics and morality is
inaccurate because politics is always
about morality
politics is always about what you think
is the right thing to do do you look
after these people or those people
do you maximize freedom or do you
maximize safety
do you give people the freedom to
succeed or fail on their merit or do you
take from the successful in order to
look after the unsuccessful that's
politics and and where you place that
marker in your own mind is about
morality so i don't think
you know i i know what you mean but i
don't think morality and politics have
ever been disconnected
but
okay i take your point and i agree with
it but it has mushroomed to such an
extent now
it has mushroomed to such an extent
whereas before
you could see people of you know left
and right sitting down having a
discussion
i think it's just because we we think in
black and white now
we don't see the shades of cray anymore
agreed it's either right or wrong you
know the good receiver right exactly
it's like what we were talking about
with the climate change thing yeah to
say what we said which is i don't know
yeah is unacceptable now yeah
i don't know if you went on tv and said
look i i
i'm a comedian i don't know about
climate change i hear some people who i
respect saying that it's happening i
hear some people who who i respect
saying
not that it's happening it's happening
because of human activity and other
people saying it's happening not because
of human activity so i don't know i
don't know what to think i'm i recycle
my i wash out my tuna tins and and
whatever
and recycle you know and i try not to
you know keep my car running when i'm
not using it that's what i do right if
you said that they'd be like yo but what
about they would make it about you
having to have an opinion yeah and
that's because everything is black and
white now
everything you can't you can't be unsure
of anything you have to you have to
commit to a particular ideological
position and i think that's where a lot
of this stuff's come from where it's
like you're either fully on the right or
you're fully on the left yes which is
ironic because the people mostly who are
pushing this way of thinking are people
who believe that you can be non-binary
yeah you can be non-binary in every way
except politically
yeah how does that doesn't make any
sense no it doesn't
you know it doesn't people want you and
i to be on the right or on the left and
you increasingly this is the thing that
worries me is people on the right are
now buying into this thing as well
because
you know the reason that in many ways i
think we get on better with people on
the right even though you and i are not
on the right is that they have at least
preserved for the most part
that tolerance
they are tolerant of people with
different opinions even if they don't
agree with them for the most part but
you're now seeing that particularly with
covid but i think more generally this
sort of like you know this idiot that
wrote an article after our david starkey
interview saying how oh you know david
stark he's not one of us because he
thinks mandatory vaccinations should be
done well you and i couldn't be more
vehemently opposed to managing
vaccinations didn't stop us from having
a really good conversation with david we
pushed back on him he said he wanted to
agree to disagree and that's what
happened but a lot of people now
are developing this black and white
thinking
on the right too
and that's a problem yeah it's a huge
problem but then filter it back into
comedy
you need people who are balanced yeah
well in order to produce the content
which makes me which
makes me think that it's it's never
going to happen and look we're going to
have conversations and look they've done
a pilot done but until i see it in front
of my eyes
until i see it done
wait i won't believe it but it's a
no-brainer francis there's got to be a
person with balls and they can be a
woman you know because it's 20 21.
there's got to be a person with balls
somewhere in a tv studio watching this
conversation right now because the
people in that world watch our show yeah
right go and they've got to know that
what i'm saying is true because it is if
people like us and other people andrew
doyle and we that we would get involved
and jeff and others made a comedy show
that punched in every direction it would
be the most successful comedy show in
this country today it would be of course
it would be because you're getting
people
you know the leos the jeffs the me the
you the andrews who we've we've had to
prove our ability to do things in spite
of the whole system being against us
yeah right so we know what we're doing
and we we've you know we've got the
pudding is there the proof of the
pudding is there so
they it's a it's a it's a slam dunk it's
a guaranteed win
if you've just got the balls to do it
what about the leader of the labour
party worms of the labour leader of the
labour party came out and went
i respect trans people but biological
sex is real and let's stop behaving like
that's what stamina should have done
yeah you should have done that i said
this
i said this the day he became leader he
needs to come out and pick a fight i
agree with you and then you can
transform the party i am not disagreeing
with you my point is he hasn't done it
yes because he's a coward right he
hasn't done it
and they're not gonna do it
it doesn't matter that's a path to
success the fact that you're right
doesn't make it any more likely to
happen
i don't agree with that though i think
the fact that i'm right means that there
will eventually come somebody who
understands that and it doesn't care
about the consequences
the short-term concept someone is
prepared to take a risk
and and just just just take the flag
for for for a few weeks and then
everyone's going to shut the [ __ ] up
about it
see this is the thing with cancel
culture man they only come after people
who are vulnerable
canceled people are just playground
bullies they only go after people who
are vulnerable that's why they've never
tried to cancel us
they have
comedians tried to get our agent to drop
us they didn't even do it properly they
talked about it it never happened
right because they know it's not going
to happen
they know it's not going to happen they
can't cancel our youtube channel they
can't cancel the show they can't cancel
my twitter they can't cancel you they
can't so they don't go after us anymore
they do go after us our instagram has
been absolutely strangled because of
complaints people have made
and as a result of that we've got a
90-day ban on our instagram we have now
got warnings on our instagram with
people try and follow us saying do you
really want to follow this this account
and we've taken views that used to be 5
000 on clips now get 150. so there's
actually no more point for us to be on
instagram really which is what i said
from the beginning yeah yeah
so just because it's not overt doesn't
mean that it's not happening what i mean
is if a tv company made a genuinely
balanced satirical show like the one
that you and i would make because we
spend more time attacking the tories on
raw than than we do anyone else [ __ ]
hate johnson yeah
so
if they just said you know if they just
came out and went
i hear that some people on twitter are
upset we at this channel believe in
creating different types of content we
fully back this project and we don't
care
there's got to be one person out there
like that just the person who's made
enough money it doesn't care anymore
there's got to be one person like that
there's got to be are you out there
because if you have i haven't [ __ ]
met you
look i love your optimism great good for
you but look i don't i it's not optimism
i'm just saying that's a possibility the
reality is if that doesn't happen
in a very cynical way
that's good for us oh yeah it's great
we'll make our own [ __ ] we'll make our
own work that was and we'll put more
resources into it and we'll keep making
it and it's going to get huge
and that's great yeah if that's that's
how they want to play it fine yeah fine
we're going to we're going to find a way
one way or another the reality is as
well tv is dead
tv is dead
the viewing figures are through the
floor i've heard on the grapevine i
don't know how true it is that this is
the last series of live at the apollo
because nobody really that's what i've
heard wow no that may not be true but
that's what i've heard on the ground
yeah the viewing figures are through the
floor nobody watches it the quality has
gone down we all know that it has
nobody's allowed to say it but it's true
if you look back at the you know halcyon
days of mcintyre of mickey flanagan of
all these people coming on and you know
and doing brilliant comedy
and packing out arenas as a result kevin
bridges doing michael mcintyre's
roadshow smashing it up simon evans
former guest of ours
to where we are now
people watch this and go well this isn't
funny
that's where we are
well on that happy note francis we'll do
some locals questions but in the
meantime guys thank you so much for
joining us for this conversation today
uh head on over to locals to see the
answers to the questions you've been
asking over there and also remember we
are doing movember for prostate cancer
uk the link should be available
somewhere in the video to support this
great cause thank you for watching and
we'll see you very soon take care and
see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below